we got a lot to talk about we're both
New Englanders I know this was stupid to
take this booking the day after the
Super Bowl I know it it was either gonna
be a joyous occasion for us but I would
look bad I'd look like the fat kid they
did all the cake you know gloating about
my team or we were gonna lose and you
know whenever my team loses a Super Bowl
we've lost five I just closed the
curtains and I stay in there for like
three days now yeah come out here
smiling and waving like I'm in a good
mood yeah and I'm not you're not in a
good mood you're angry you're angry
about the Super Bowl no it's just sucked
yeah those no defense the whole damn
game they got that two punts it just I
don't know wasn't good I told my wife
right after guy Mike I'm fine I'm fine
we went five oh yeah I'm going to just
drove home in total silence then we got
into somehow got an argument about Janet
Jackson you know about the whole that
incident year yes exactly yeah I didn't
have any sympathy for it was like it was
network television you know I wouldn't
take my balls out on NBC at the game you
know and expect that people watching
wouldn't have a problem with it it was a
sorority it was more interest in her
breasts than your balls to be frank I'm
just gonna say I would slight difference
in interest there yes there definitely
is did you break down there's different
parts of the game a lot of the winglet
fans get upset that Brady didn't catch
that pass Super Bowl he should have laid
out he should have his whole body and
grabbed it you know it was funny it was
well on that play you actually saw his
age you know if you sweat he stands in
the pocket he looks 25 the second he
starts running it's like dude I could be
this guy up last year when he threw that
pick six when he dove to tackle that guy
it looked like somebody threw a dead
body out of a car
it's our move and that was it but he
what he stands in the pocket he looks
like an astronaut yeah yes guys he's
gonna live forever
yeah like cocoon us up yeah so when he
missed that past that was that they
threw to him when he was the receiver
you felt a little better about your age
okay this guy he can't I couldn't get a
I knew I was nervous before the game cuz
the Eagles had evidently had this great
defense and they didn't stop anybody
either was the weirdest game and and
then they had that trick play with Nick
Foles
and Collinsworth just kept talking about
the most unbelievable Twitter clamor
it's like the Patriots just ran that
play you seem unhappy about this game
yeah no I'm unhappy that I got a sinner
and I can't be all excited and start
promoting stuff I'm not in a you know
when your team loses a championship game
it's like you don't go on Facebook you
don't go on Twitter you just you just
don't answer your phone you just do that
until like baseball season and then it's
fine yeah well thank you you're on
national television sitting doors later
yeah I got to relive the death all over
again
you